nous avons fait jusque là le choix d'un
usage rationnel raisonnable raisonnée
des tests rationnelle car il ya une
logique qui prévaut lors de chaque
épidémie
quand un virus circule vite ne pas
dépister de manière systématique mais
basé le suivi sur la surveillance des
symptômes
c'est ce que nous faisons chaque hiver
lorsque nous gérons par exemple
l'épidémie de grippe résonnait car
réaliser des tests mobilise
d'importantes ressources qu'il s'agisse
de la mobilisation des professionnels
pour prélever ou des réactifs pour les
réaliser les tests ne servent pas à
mesurer mais à contenir l'épidémie
en la matière je rappelle que nous
sommes depuis le premier jour
parfaitement alignés sur les
recommandations et pratiques
internationales au stade 1 au stade 2
nous avons testé l'ensemble des cas
contact des personnes malades
ce qui nous a par exemple permis un
contrôle remarquable souvenez-vous du
foyer de contamines montjoie en haute
savoie
j'avais même souhaité aller plus loin en
procédant au dépistage systématique chez
tous malades hospitalisés en réanimation
ou soins intensifs avec des troubles
respiratoires sévères
aujourd'hui nous ne détestons pas de
façon automatique
car nous avons fait un choix comme la
plupart des pays et conformément aux
recommandations de la commission
européenne de réserver les tests à des
publics prioritaires les personnes
ciblées sont comme chez nos voisins
européens
les personnes les plus à risques et les
professionnels de santé
symptomatique les personnes âgées
symptomatique les personnes qui
présentent des difficultés respiratoires
sévères ou d'éco mobilité c'est-à-dire
des fragilités des maladies chroniques
les personnes hospitalisées et tout
nouveau foyer ou nouveaux territoires
jusqu'ici épargnée par l'épidémie en
france nous avons aussi fait le choix
complémentaire de prioriser les femmes
enceintes les donneurs d'organes les
donneurs de cellules les donneurs de
tissu
chaque jour ce sont plus de 4000 tests
qui sont effectués sur ces personnes
nous avons atteint un total supérieur à
60 mille tests réalisés dans notre pays
actuellement 70 laboratoire en plus des
50 déjà équipés sont en capacité de
réaliser des tests
nous sommes ainsi parmi les premiers
pays européens en matière de capacité de
dépistage et nous souhaitons monter en
puissance
la capacité journalière de réalisation
des tests va ainsi continuer d'augmenter
ce n'est pas là une simple hypothèse de
travail c'est un impératif de santé
publique
la doctrine d'usagé rationnelle et
raisonnée des tests doivent évoluer
lundi dernier le docteur tedros
président de l'organisme directeur
général de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a délivré ce message simple tester
tester tester la france doit donc
désormais suivre cette voie et se
préparer à faire évoluer rapidement sa
stratégie de dépistage
l'enjeu c'est d'être en mesure de
multiplier nos capacités de test
au moment où nous lèverons le
confinement c'est l'enjeu
au moment où nous le voulons confinement
au moment où nous permettons à chacune
et chacun de reprendre le cours normal
de sa vie
nous devrons pouvoir vérifier que les
personnes pour lesquelles il y avait un
doute présenter ou non la maladie
cliquant jeudi multiplier cela veut dire
multiplier pas juste augmenter sans
attendre nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des industriels en france
comme à l'étranger pour augmenter ses
capacités de test dans les plus brefs
délais l'espoir je le dis est aussi
tournée vers la recherche qui pourrait
nous permettre d'ici à quelques semaines
je dis bien pourrait nous permettre
d'ici à quelques semaines de disposer
d'une nouvelle méthode diagnostique plus
simple plus rapide plus largement
diffusé à bhl sur tout le territoire
national
vous l'avez compris ce n'est pas sur la
base d'un dépistage massif que nous
mettrons fin
confinement mais c'est sur la base d'un
dépistage massif que nous pourrions être
amenés à accroître notre surveillance
une fois le confinement levées